Fair Community World fig Community world
yes sir t-rell and A.D are in the
building yes congratulations fellas
it's good to see y'all I'd like to also
start this interview by pointing out
that a lot of people seem to think that
I had replaced y'all or some and
that was not yeah
why
I definitively got hit up at lunch uh
the day all that stuff has happened by
Adam and he asked if I wanted to just
because I've been a guest on the show
before he's like hey you want to fill in
for a day and I had said yes prior to
understanding what was going on exactly
what was going on I heard that the Lush
guy got fired and I was like oh well
that's you know and then I called you
and then you were like
I was like ah well it should be
interesting hey though I said go do it
no no for sure yeah I'm saying Lush 2.0
here folks
man I don't know I don't know that he
called Lush wax and I said he called him
corny I said I said I said I don't know
dude but like watching him on camera he
comes off like a cornball and so then he
went on some podcasts a bunch of people
tagged me in and what's up with all
y'all with this white on white crime I
don't I have no problems with that guy
y'all just me everybody I really got
zero problems with that dude like I
don't know him like he's he's dead he's
definitively my Elder he has to be older
white people got problems with each
other you're gonna have to take your
first fate in hip-hop dawg be like a
part here I'm like whatever yeah no no
he says I don't think it's any problems
with that dude you know what I mean
anyway congrats guys yes congrats to you
because the spot thank you
very inspiring you guys are killing it
um I mean there's been a lot of uh
you know a lot of narratives about you
guys have popped up on a lot of places
so I think this probably is this the
first time besides your own platforms
you guys have been on camera talking
about this because you guys have been on
like academics thing yeah on camera yeah
this is the first thing I told I told
everybody we weren't gonna uh talk about
nothing until we was all together but uh
you know since we like you I'm glad that
I'm pungent come to pack me out yeah put
them whooping ass right now he been
whooping ass all week Jesus I mean
sometimes you need that you know what
I'm saying so we can relax and do our
thing
um give me like an idea of what fig
Community world is gonna be because
obviously uh the Youtube channel was
started a while ago
here we go
is that where we're gonna start no I'm
just I I'm you know when you go to the
page
um good there's a bunch of y'all on
there obviously smack you pun duno
um who like like is it gonna be because
the Wednesday show is obviously
something that the fans are gonna miss
you guys are going to be on your own
version of that we're doing Wednesdays
live I mean so yeah fig Community world
but basically is our Network so we'll
just definitely become no jumper we'll
ease into that you know somewhere it's a
bunch of uh podcasts and different shows
different Vlogs like you know different
series and stuff like that so we'll
we'll we'll begin with what we already
have right now which is uh a Wednesday
show and we named it we renamed it shame
on you at the end of the day and uh
we'll take the um we hungry show which
is their food show great show by the way
we starving or something yeah something
like that
it's hard to do a food show with
somebody who only likes to eat french
fries okay he gotta change his palette
are you saying you have white trash food
uh taste because no no no I mean my
favorite food is french fries so don't
hate on me he goes a nice hotel give me
a french fries you see that White Band
with the headphones on over there same
thing all he does is eat fries
are they selling macaroni and cheese
more french fries as a side
okay